Aaaah vous allez bien ?
Moi bof : on m'a volé mon ordinateur.
En gros j'rentrais du boulot et j'suis allé dans une brasserie avec des potes,
j'ai pas eu le temps de rentrer chez moi pour déposer mon ordinateur DONC j'avais mon ordinateur...
dans mon sac,
à mes pieds ;
un couple s'est installé derrière moi, ils ont déplacé mon sac, derrière mon siège,
ils ont pris mon ordinateur et ils sont partis avant d'avoir consommé.
Au moment où j'ai compris qu'on m'avait volé mon ordinateur, avec
j'ai euh... j'ai buggé.
Naaan allez il est où ?
De quoi tu parles ?
Voilà. Euh... J'ai buggé comme ça pendant à peu près... 5 minutes.
P'têt' me rebooter là, non...? Euh...
Alors le premier truc que j'ai fait, c'est aller dans le commissariat le plus proche,
et dans ma tête ça allait s'passer comme ça :
On m'a volé mon ordinateur !
Quoi ?!
Où ça ?
Dans une brasserie ! Là-bas !
Un couple installé derrière vous ? Un ordinateur qui disparaît ?
Comment savez-vous ?
Je reconnais ce mode opératoire, le voleur est connu des forces de police !
Montez dans cette voiture !
On va l'coincer !
Mais non ! Non, ce... ça s'est passé comme ça :
On a volé mon ordinateur !
D'accord. Il va falloir attendre une heure, monsieur.
Ah...!
Asseyez-vous !
Ha ha ha ha ha, ha ha ha ha ha ! J'ai volé un ordinateur ! Ha ha h...!
Hop là.
Alors... Leboncoin...
– Ok, nickel !
– Ok.
– Bonne soirée !
– Allez à plus !
Au bout d'une heure d'attente c'est à mon tour,
et là :
Et donc voilà toute l'histoire.
Voilà !
Bonne journée !
Alors je savais qu'on allait pas retrouver mon ordinateur comme ça hein, ça euh...
Mais bon euh...
Une feuille, quoi...
Si j'étais toi je ne volerais pas cet ordinateur.
Sinon...
ON VA ME DONNER UNE FEUILLE.
Oh mon Dieu...!
Une feuille ?!
Psst !
Non, non !
MAIS je n'en suis pas resté là !
Comme mon ordinateur était de la marque Apple,
j'ai pu utiliser la fonction "Localiser",
qui te permet de faire deux choses :
si le voleur se connecte à Internet avec mon ordinateur je peux soit
le localiser, savoir où il est,
MAIS
i'peut faire c'qui veut avec mon ordinateur.
Ah...! Il a une chaîne YouTube !
“Supprimer”.
Aaaah !
F'rais bien un p'tit café, moi.
SOIT je peux verrouiller l'ordinateur,
MAIS
je sais pas où il est.
J'ai pris la deuxième option, euh... par sécurité.
Il a une page Facebook, aussi !
Alors...
Je
n'aime
pas
les
noirs.
Le plus fort c'est qu'avec cette option,
on peut même écrire un message, qui va s'afficher sur l'ordinateur volé.
Là j'vous l'dis...!
De tous... De tous les messages, euh... qui peuvent exister sur la planète Terre
en terme de dissuasion, de c'que vous voulez,
j'ai choisi :
Comme si le voleur
allait se dire :
“Voler, c'est m...”
Bonjour ! Euh... J'vous rends votre ordinateur, hein, parce que c'est mal de voler.
Merci !
Maint'nant j'vais faire du... bénévolat. Au r'voir !
Du coup j'ai reçu un mail d'Apple qui m'explique que le voleur a effectivement tenté de se connecter,
mais que l'ordinateur s'est bien verrouillé, et euh... faites-moi plaisir :
faites attention à vos affaires, voilà.
Ah oui !
J'ai une petite surprise pour vous,
sur mon téléphone.